好，我們來繼續，繼續。同樣在這本講義的第13頁，13頁。
好，我們來看這個 n 喔，n，在台羅字是 n 喔。
n-a na，藍色的藍，或是籃子的籃，n-a na，第五調，第五調。
再來 n-e ne，ne。
我們說這樣，這樣，這個腔調不同。
再來 ni，藍色的藍，ni，ni。
還有這字，另外一個音叫做 ng，五點的五，五點的五。
好，再來下面，n-o no，no。
這個長老叫做長老，長老，no。
再來下面，卵，這個華語的蛋，就叫做卵，卵。
第七調，卵，第七調。
所以它的聲調有標在 ng 的 n 上面，ng 的 n 上面。
好，再來 l-a la，la，這字 la。
l-e le，le 是第七調的 le，le。
失禮的禮，好。再來 l-i li，li，第七調，li，li。
這個我們那個什麼里，里民的里啦。好，再來 l-o lo，lo。
這個不是姓，姓 lo，lo，l-o lo，lo。
再來囉唆的囉，口字旁，l-o lo，口字旁再一個 lo，lo。
再來 l-o-o loo，l-o loo，loo。
和那個滷肉的滷一樣，不過字不同，工藝的工，loo。
再來 lu，仙女，也有人講仙女，腔調不同，仙女，仙女。
好，再來 k，k-a ka，ka。
加油的加，加油的加。
說到加油，我們華語所說去加油站加油，去加油站加油，我們台語怎麼說？
加油，加油，加油。我們台語比較正統的說法是什麼？添油。
有聽過嗎？我爸都說，我來去，來去添油，我來去加油站添油。
前面那個添是三點水再一個真，添，華語的添，添油，添，用添的，油用添的。
而我們台語說加油是什麼？鼓勵加油叫做加油。
我們會說，這次考試要加油喔，好，不是叫你去加油站加油，是你愛加油。
所以我們如果說去加那個燃料，我們會說添油，添油，好。
再來下面 ke，同樣，加減的加，我們會說 ke。
所以加減我們唸做加減，所以你看一個字就有兩個音，一個叫做 ka，一個叫做 ke。
多講的，多講。
像我們以前在上班的時候，啊你多講的，多講。
多講，多講的，多講。好，再來 k-i ki，這個 ki，基本的基。
那個開基，開基，像我們台灣很多喔，台南那邊古城很多開基。
開基祖啦，他們那個廟寺的廟，開基的，開基廟，ki。好，再來 k-o ko，ko。
什麼 ko，這個什麼案，什麼 ko 什麼 ko 的 ko 啦。好，再來 k-o ko，這都知道，阿姑的姑。
還有香菇的菇也是，香菇的菇。而我們台語有一個教訓無心。
做這個要吃菇，香菇的菇，香菇的菇，要吃菇，意思就是說，沒有意義。好。
再來 k-u ku，ku。所以我們華語說烏龜。
而我們台語說一個字就好，龜。嘿，我們華語的烏龜就是台語的龜。
你不要兩個字照唸，萬一你兩個字照唸叫做烏龜，是烏龜喔，烏龜。
烏龜就是那個拉皮條的，烏龜。皮條客。
好，再來 k-ng kng，這個光明的光，kng，kng。
k-ng，那唸做 ng 喔，k-ng kng，kng，光，光明的光。
而那個扛，提手旁再一個工，也是唸做 kng。扛轎的扛。好。
再來 kh，kh-a kha，這字第七調，kha。吃巧不吃飽，吃巧不吃飽。
kh-a kha。這字巧，還有另外一個同音，叫做 khiàu，聰明就是這字，叫做 khiàu，就這字巧。
好，再來 kh-e khe，第一調 khe，這都知道。所以我們說那個。
都是別人的錯，嫌東嫌西，不會開船嫌溪彎。
不會開船嫌溪彎。好，再來 kh-i khi，欺騙的欺，欺，早起的起。
kh-o kho，這大家都知道，一科二科。再來 kh-o kho，kho，第七調，kho，kho。
這個救苦的苦。再來 kh-u khu，這都知道，第一調，khu。
再來下面，米糠的糠，kh-ng khng，khng，khng，米糠的糠，米糠的糠。
好，再來後面，這個 g，濁音，濁音，g。
g-a gâ，第五調，gâ，gâ。gâ 是什麼你知道嗎？螺絲，螺絲那個紋，螺絲鉸。
螺絲鉸，而他們黑手都說，那個螺紋如果磨損了，就跋鉸，螺絲跋鉸。
跋鉸是日語，他們黑手界很多都用這字，還用這字。所以我們用台羅拼音才有辦法拼它的音。
漢字不一定寫得出來。之前說那個螺絲起子，他們都我們台羅都台羅拼音，他們一些工務工具都用這字。
好，再來第二組，g-e gê，gê，gê，第七調，gê，gê。
那個牙齒的牙。你如果唸做牙齒就變成第三調，gê，gê。
再來 g-i gî，gî，gî。所以宜蘭，我們唸做宜蘭，Gî-lân。
所以華語很多，義理的義，義理，也會唸做 g-i gî，gî，都唸做宜蘭。
好，再來 g-o gô，gô，gô。而海口那邊，我們中部海口他們唸做什麼？鵝肉。
giâ，我有去過他們家，他們家住在那個梧棲那邊，我去他們家，他媽媽說，你要吃鵝肉嗎？
鵝肉，我聽不懂，我聽不懂。原來他們那個鵝肉。好，再來五，五，g-o gōo，gōo。
第七調，gōo，五月五。再來 g-u gû，這都知道，第五調，gû。
再來第三種濁音，ng，ng，ng。ng-a ngá，雅，優雅的雅，優雅的雅。
而如果是我們台中北邊那個，叫做大雅，ngé，它是變成 n-g-e-2，第二調，ngé。
好，再來 e，n-g-e ngē，ngē，它是第七調，ngē，ngē。
ngē 是什麼？困難的，不好做的，叫做硬。而你都挑軟的，我都吃硬的。
你專挑軟柿子，而不好、困難的就留給我。我都吃硬的，你都吃軟的。
所以軟的就寫做軟，這都是我們台語的一種藝術，我們台語很多藝術。
軟的，硬的。
你如果是華語人就聽不懂，這是什麼？可以吃嗎？他是在形容事情。
而你都挑軟的，我都吃硬的。好，再來下面，再來這個 ng-i ngî。
同樣它是不同腔調，我們說硬(ngē)說硬(ngî)啦，ngî。下面，這個我，n-g-o-o ngóo。
ngóo，ngóo。
五，布袋戲，五，五指梳。
布袋戲，五指梳，這原本就有，布袋戲，現在布袋戲很愛講。
現在都用 AI，AI 會說話，都用 AI 說話，以前真的是用人，人去搬演。
布袋戲那個手，在那個偶裡面撐，那個叫什麼？撐布袋。
撐，撐，那個撐，提手旁再一個撐，撐。再來我們的 ts，ts-a tsa，紮紮的紮。
再來 ts-e tse，第五調 tsê，齊。
所以我們常常聽到一句話，齊齊，寫作齊齊，另外一個音讀作 tsiau，也是寫成整齊的齊。
齊齊讀作 tsiau-tsê，還有 tsiau-ûn，這齊，整齊，整齊，整齊的齊，整齊。再來 ts-i tsi，tsi，什麼 tsi？支票的支。
這另外一個音讀作 ki，單位量詞，ki，一枝兩枝的 ki，我們另外說的單位量詞，還有一個木字旁的 ki，那不一樣，總之 ts 的物體的體積不一樣。
再來 ts-o tso，做，做的做，ts-o tso，第二調做。再來 ts-oo tsoo，租，租，租車租金。
租金，這個租我們在台語裡面用在動詞，動作動詞的時候，租房子，租厝，租厝，我們用 suè。
租厝，租，租厝，租，房客，厝跤，厝跤，或是房東叫做厝跤頭，這用 suè，租厝。
父母如果說，他在外面租房子居住的，居住的站起來的站，居住，租房子居住的，就是租賃住的。
再來下面，那個資料的資，ts-u tsu，tsu，資料，tsu。
下面，化妝的妝，tsng，tsng，洗妝打扮的妝，tsng。
再來隔壁欄 tsh，tsh-a tsha，差，精差，精差，精差的精是精神的精，就是精度有差啦，精準度有差，叫做精差。
精差，就是差異，精差。再來 tsh-e tshe，妻，妻孥。
妻，這有寫人，妻孥不可傷，妻孥不可傷。再來 tsh-i tshi，七，七，七月的七，白痴的七。
再來 tsh-oo tshoo，燥，燥燥的燥，寫成這個，肉燥的燥，華語的肉燥的燥，燥燥的燥，tsh-oo tshoo，燥燥的燥。
再來 tsh-o tsho，粗，粗與細，相反詞就是細，粗與細。再來 tsh-u tshu，這字是什麼 tshu？鋪皮。
鋪皮，鋪皮，鋪，它平鋪的，平鋪的就是用 tshu。
再來下面，倉庫的倉，大家都會唸，tsh-ng tshng，tshng，倉庫的倉，tshng。
再來 s，s-a sa，炸，炸。再來 s-e se，洗，洗，洗衣服的洗。
再來 s-i si，師，老師的師。再來 s-o so，鎖，鎖匙的鎖，鎖，所以現在的鎖匙店，他們都要去寫鎖匙店，鑰匙店。
他們都會寫，大家才會看懂，鎖，鎖，鎖匙的鎖。
鎖匙的鎖要怎麼寫？鎖匙的鎖，鎖，鎖，鎖匙的鎖，奢侈的奢，奢，奢，奢華奢侈的奢，奢。
奢，奢華奢侈的奢，奢，奢，這大字，這大字要怎麼寫？鎖匙的鎖，奢侈的奢，奢。
奢華奢侈的奢，奢，奢，這大字要怎麼寫？鎖匙的鎖，現在的鎖匙店，看板，看板都是用這個，這個像框框這個。
這個鎖，鎖。再來 s-oo soo，so，so，還有什麼？很酥脆的酥，也是這字，也是這音 so。
再來 s-u su，輸贏的輸。再來 s-ng sng，這字 sng，與，這字 sng 還有另外一字同音，但是不同的地方不同。
這個是身體痠痛的痠，那這個是味覺，嘴巴裡的味覺，酸，或是說那個心靈感受，心酸的酸，這個是身體生理上的。
好，我們來看 j，j，j 較少，j-i ji，ji，第七調 ji，ji。
所以 ji 呢，我們有一句說，一定要有，一定一定要有文字，請再保留它的文化與紀錄，所以我們說，話是風，字是蹤。
失蹤的蹤，蹤，就是話是風，說過就沒了，你有紀錄，以前沒什麼錄音，沒什麼手機可以錄音，話是風。
話是風，字是蹤，行蹤的蹤，失蹤的蹤，字是蹤，就是它有過，才會走過留下痕跡。
再來 ju，這個 j-u ju，如，如果的如，不如的如。再來 h，h-a ha，ha，這字 ha 是 ha 什麼？
喝茶喔，來找喝兩杯茶，喝，這字喝茶的喝。
再來 h-e he，he，第七調 he，什麼大學什麼系科系的系，科系的 he。
再來 h-i hi，第七調 hi，hi，稀罕的 hi。再來 h-oo hoo，第五調 hôo，河，河川的河。
再來 h-o ho，ho，這個 ho，呼叫呼叫的 ho。h-u hu，hu，呼吸的 hu。再來這字 h-m hm，這就真罕見喔，看下面。
第五調 h-m hm，姆，姆婆，姆婆，姆婆。
再來最後一個剛才說過，公園的園，公園，h-ng hng，公園。
來，第 14 頁，這是介音與主要母音，我們這先略過，我們來看主要母音是那個 ng 的，我們來看第 18 頁，第 18 頁這都 ng 的。
有的人常常，每次上課都有聽到一些 ng 發音發得不好，發得不好，來我們看這款鼻音尾，就是母音加韻尾是 ng 的。
〔此段辨識失敗〕
正常，吃力，對吧？
我們台語就非常快意喔
這本很吃力，吃力
就是很嚴重，吃力
很吃力，我們朋友也很吃力，吃力
其實它要唸文讀音也可以，叫做「實力」，「實力」的「實」
「實力」喔，好
再下來，和，這個「筆」，這個「筆」的「筆」，這都知道，筆
再來，「逼」的「逼」，被逼迫的「逼」，「逼」
再來，「鼻」，「鼻」，「鼻」，第四聲的「鼻」，鼻子的「鼻」
鼻有一個形容詞叫做「鼻鼻」
不乾脆，做事情拖泥帶水的喔
好，再來，「不」，「不」是什麼？「不定義」的「不」，語音部分也是，「不」，「不定義」的「不」
好，「ph」，「ph」這個，喔，「幅」，覆蓋的「幅」，「幅」，「幅」
這個「幅」是什麼？「幅」
「幅」就是，喔，覆蓋的「幅」這個「幅」，「幅」
「幅」我們也常常講喔
再來，「ph-a-pha」，剛才講的，「打字」的「打」，「打字」的「打」
好，下面，這個「ph-i-phi」，「鼻」，「鼻」，第四聲的「鼻」
再來，「ph-e-phe」，「撇」，「撇」，文讀音也是，這個字「撇」，「撇」
再來，「ph-i-phi」，「譬」，「譬相」，「譬相」就是，加上那個，揶揄啦
「譬相」很難聽的，「譬」喔
下面這個「ph-u-phu」，「phu」就是拿刀，揮，用揮動的去砍，叫做「phu」
「phu草」啦，或是講這個「phu旗過海」那個「phu」喔，動作比較快，力道比較大的「phu」
好，「m」，「m-a-h-mah」，「嘛」，「嘛」，「嘛」
這個喔，是放在語尾，喔，你也跟我講一個嘛，嘛，嘛
好，再下面這個「m-i-mi」，「味」，這個「食物」，好食物，好吃的東西，「食物」，食物，我們也講「食物」，也講「食物」，味
好，下面，再來，「m-a-t-mat」，「密」，喔，這個「密密」，「密密」，「密」，這個「密」，「密密」
再來，「m-a-k-mak」，「目」，「目」，這個「做目」，就是木工、木匠，「目」，再來，「肉」，肉，這都知道
好，「b-i-bi」，「香味」的「味」，「味」
再來，「b-e-be」，「妙」，這個是那個，幽默，我們如果叫這個叫做「幽妙」，「幽妙」
好，再下面，「b-i-bi」，寫作「避見」，就是躲起來的意思
喔，整個「避見」去，不讓人看到「避見」叫做「避」，「捉迷藏」，「捉迷藏」躲貓貓，「捉迷藏」
「揣」是提手旁，這個「揣」
「捉迷藏」的「避」，躲起來
好，再來，「t」，這個「答」，「回答」的「答」，「t-a-p-tap」
「t-a-t-tat」，「踏」，「踏」，有這個名，還有那個「到踏」，你如果要講「到踏」，「到踏」，「到踏」的「踏」
再來，「t-a-k-tak」，這個「逐」，「大家」，「大家」的「逐」，「逐」
再來，「t-a-h-tah」，「t-a-h-tah」，「tah」，「tah」，「tah」，「tah」
這個唸作「tah」，「疊被」的「疊」
再下面，直直的「直」，「t-i-k-tik」，「直」，再來，敵人的「敵」，「t-i-k-tik」，「敵」，「無敵」的「敵」
再來，「t-i-h-tih」，「筷子」，「筷子」
再來，「t-u-t-tut」，「t-u-t-tut」，「tut」
有一個「戇tut」，「戇tut」的「tut」
「th」，「th-a-p-thap」，「thap」，「填空」叫做「thap-khang」
「thap-khang」，填空，就像講我們那個，那個考古題，填空，我們會寫作「thap-khang」
這個「thap」，凹下去的凹，叫做「thap」，就像講那個「眼睛」，「睭睭」，眼眶凹陷，「睭睭」
好，再下面，「th-a-t-that」，這個「踢」都知道，用腳踢，再下面，「th-a-k-thak」，「th-a-k-thak」，「讀書」的「讀」
所以讀書，我們會用，不用「書」，用「冊」，冊子的「冊」，「讀書」
好，再來，「塔」，這個「塔」都知道，「水塔」的「塔」
再下面這個「th-i-k-thik」，「剔」，「剔牙」的「剔」
「th-i-t-thit」，「遊玩」的「thit」，日字旁還有一個「迌」，「迌」是辵，辵部還有一個「月」部，叫做「遊玩」
「遊玩」就有兩個意思，一個是玩耍，一個是在江湖上跟人混喔
下面，「th-e-k-thek」，「斥」，「排斥」的我們講「排斥」，「排斥」，排列的「排」，「排斥」一樣，寫作那個「斥」
這個「斥」我們用作「thek」，「排斥」
好，再來，「恥」，這都知道
再來，「th-u-t-thut」，「ut」唸作「ut」，「th-ut-thut」，「禿頭」，「禿頭」，「禿尖」
好，下面，後面，「n」，「n-a-na」，「那」，「燖那」，「燖那」是什麼？閃電，華語的閃電，「燖那」的「那」寫作這個「那」
還有一個「那日」，「那日」是什麼？「那日」就是像我們現在開始入秋，這樣那個，太陽，沒出來的時間越來越短
「那日」就是太陽出來一下下，叫做「那日」
下面，「n-i-h-nih」，「踮腳尖」的「nih」，踮腳尖，踮腳尖叫做「踮腳尖」的「nih」，這個「nih」
再把竹字旁改成木字旁，同樣也是唸作「nih」，就是眨眼的眨，眨眼睛
「眨一下」的「眨」，就是它的部首，它的這個字邊改成「目」
好，「l」，「l-a-p-lap」，「納」，「納稅金」的「納」
好，下面，「l-a-t-lat」，「力」，它是第八調，「力」，「力草」的「力」，「力草」就是力量、力道
「l-a-k-lak」也是同樣第八調，「落」，「落」這個「落」，「落」我們都第八調我們都唸作「落」，它是第八調的「落」
再來，「打la」的「la」，「la」，「l-a-h-lah」，「la」
再來，立正的「立」，「l-i-p-lip」，「立」
好，再下面，暱稱的「暱」，「l-i-t-lit」，「it」唸作「it」也是，「l-i-t-lit」，「暱」
下面，力量的「力」，「l-i-k-lik」，它是第八調，「力」，「力」
所以一個字就有兩個音，「力」也有一個叫做「lat」，一個叫做「lik」
再來，「l-i-h-lih」，「ih」唸作「i」，「l-i-lih」，「lih」
這個是動詞，也是單位，單位量詞，「lih」，「一lih」
它是第八調喔，「lih」，「一lih」，或是寫作「裂」的「裂」，「一lih」
後面那個「一lih」，它是單位詞，前面是動詞，裂開的「裂」，就裂開一個縫，「一lih」
就像講，喔，我的衣服喔，太，太窄，這樣，破掉，裂一縫
那個「褲腳」也是，那個「褲腳」那個「一縫」，這樣，就是裂開，裂開一個縫
好，再來，律師的「律」，「u-t-ut」，「l-ut-lut」，「律師」的「律」
好，再來，「k-a-p-kap」，「k-a-p-kap」，「kap」
這個「kap-á」，這是「kap-á」，「kap-á」是什麼？青蛙
不要被華文誤導喔，這「kap」，「kap-á」是青蛙，又叫做「四腳仔」
你有聽過「田蛤仔」嗎？「田蛤仔」
就是這樣，它這個「田沒講」，「kap-á」就是青蛙，「田蛤仔」、「kap-á」、「四腳仔」都叫做青蛙
Frog，這個字是青蛙的意思
我剛才強調說不要被華文，不要被華文誤導喔
他要講「蛤仔」對吧？「蛤仔」的「蛤」
好，謝謝，好吧。接下來這個蛤蜊。
我有一天在，在臉書看到一張相片，有一台貨車，他們在，他們在...
做蛤蜊的，蛤蜊的批發，他的車上面寫「掌聲」。
蛤蜊蛤蜊，唸作「掌聲」，鼓勵鼓勵寫「掌聲」，他就寫「蛤蜊蛤蜊」。
蛤蜊就是這個蛤蜊，蛤蜊。
而「蛤仔」是青蛙，青蛙是青蛙。所以不要看到他這個，喔，你就說這蛤蜊，不是喔。
蛤蜊是這樣寫。這個「蛤」字還有什麼？眼眶，眼眶。這個「蛤」字。
好，接下來 KAT，KAT。K、A、T。我們剛才說過，打死結的「結」。
接下來 KAK，K、A、K。角。那個，剛才有八角嘛，還有一個八角嗎？那個也是有肉的，肉的滷味，八角。
接下來 KAH，K-A-H，K、A、H。甲。這個字呢，有幾個意思，一個就是我們一般知道，土地面積的單位，一甲、兩甲的「甲」。
好，接下來，第二個，程度，程度副詞。我們「甲」那天，「甲」。它是一個華語「到」的意思。還有，我們說這件東西怎麼會...
好吃到... 就好吃到... 這樣。就好吃到難以形容，好吃到。
如果你要形容說，好吃到... 靠北。啊好吃到這樣，我們台語說「到這樣」，就是說那個，那個程度你自己去體會。
這樣說好吃到。前面，前面說，好吃到啦、跳到，喔，那個「跳到」是一首歌嘛。跳到、爽到，就是這個「甲」字。
程度副詞，就是這個「甲」字喔。他這個是，好吃到，它是雙連字，所以唸兩個音，好吃到。它原本是「甲」喔。
好，接下來 KIP，急。急急的「急」。這個嘴唇要合起來。P，嘴唇要合起來，急。
好，接下來，急急的「急」。IG 唸作「ig」，K、I、急。急急。好，那個急急，急急都在宜蘭比較多啦。
接下來 IK 唸作「ik」，K、I、革。革命，革命的「革」。
好，接下來 IH，I。K、I、七。七。七。一、二、三、四、五、六、七。K、I、七。七。IH 嘛，I、I。它不是「ik」喔，它是「ih」。K、I、七。七。這個字比較少見。
好，接下來 UT，un。K、U、T。滑。滑。滑溜的「滑」。這大家都知道。
好，KH，ㄎ。KHAT，ㄎ、啊、磕。磕頭。還有什麼？碰不到。碰不到。
動不動就怎樣，碰不到。
碰不到，動不動，碰不到要怎樣怎樣怎樣。碰不到到處跑。
好，接下來 AT，at。ㄎ、啊、磕。動詞，咬。華語的「咬」。好，名詞，勺子。較大的湯勺，kha-la̍h。
而古早人都用那個瓢，瓢，kha-la̍h。kha-la̍h。
這個字還有舌頭的「kha̍h」。舌頭的「kha̍h」。
好，接下來 AK，ak。ㄎ、啊、殼。帶殼。殼。什麼殼？魚殼、什麼蝦殼的「殼」。
接下來 AH，ah。ㄎ、啊、較。這個就是，比較怎樣。較。我比較愛吃什麼，比較，比較怎樣。
好，ㄎ、IP 唸作「ip」，ㄎ、伊、吸。剛才說過，吸管的「吸」。
好，接下來 IT，it。ㄎ、伊、乞。乞丐的「乞」。乞丐的「乞」。乞丐的華語寫作「乞丐」。我們要寫這個字，乞食。
乞食。所以呢，我們有時說，去吃、去吃，這樣說，去吃、去吃。你罵我，喔，去吃。
好，接下來 IK 唸作「ik」，ㄎ、伊、曲。歌曲的「曲」。
好，IH，I。ㄎ、伊、缺。缺。缺是什麼？缺角。缺角。我們說碗、碗有缺角喔。缺角。
碗缺一角，我們唸作缺角。碗缺一角、兩角、三角，缺角。缺一角。就缺一個角，缺角。K-H-I-H，缺角。
碗缺一角喔。它也是單位詞，角。好，接下來 UT，un。K-H，ㄎ、溫、窟。窟窿的「窟」。窟。
好，這樣知道了。好，我們先這樣。中場休息。